today I'm talking about making it pop um
so this is going to be a different uh
let's see if I can get this to pause
here there we go this is going to be a
different talk than your typical
technical talk at GS comp and that's not
pausing so it's going to be pain in the
butt oh there we go there we go we'll
just go like this like this I did have a
pause oh there we go it's not playing
yeah there we go all right good start so
um this is going to be a little bit
different of a talk it's about visual
design and how many of you are just
building JavaScript apps all the time
how many of you have like side projects
you're working on anybody cool so I mean
there I'm in the right crowd um so this
design is about making the apps you
build in JavaScript with your amazing
code just as beautiful as your
JavaScript code so I'm Kyle Lambert I'm
heading up design at ol arc I work for o
lard were an awesome company it's a lot
of fun to work there designer developer
but mostly focused on design there and
one of my things at work that I'm trying
to do is scale our design team we have a
bunch of really talented front-end
developers and they are perfectly
capable of making design decisions we
like to code and ship really fast so
trying to get stopped by the bottleneck
of a designer sometimes
sometimes it's tough just needs to get
shipped and done and so my goal Oh lark
is to equip our engineers to make really
good design decisions just like their
goals is to make me a better engineer so
this talk is kind of about that and
things you guys can keep in mind while
doing that so why talk about visual
design that Jas comp well I wasn't
planning on talking at jas comp but our
engineers kind of pushed me into it we
do weekly tech talks at o lark and I
gave atop this talk and apparently they
thought it'd be good for the jas crowd
so they convinced me to do it so we're
just going to go for it but i think the
benefit of having your design team and
development team in communication with
each other and able to communicate with
each other it's so important it really
helps with collaboration it helps make
the process so much faster and it makes
everybody just a better all overall
maker we all have the desire to build
stuff from the ground up by ourselves
like if I can't I can design things but
if I don't learn how to code I'll never
be able to make my own application
myself and design it myself same thing
with engineers you're never going to be
able to you could build an awesome app
that looks great on the back end but if
it makes no sense on the front end it
might not make sense for your users so i
thought jay is comp played this funny
little trick on me I took the screenshot
last week as they added me to the
schedule and notice I'm the only one
with a broken I'm the only talk here
that's actually breaking the design of
the schedule so well played jazz comp I
don't know if that was intentional but
I'm going to I'm gonna if it wasn't just
claim it as it was because it's awesome
so why design matters so we're doing a
lot of things when we design things
we're helping communicate to our users
we're helping build trust we're
preparing people for decisions we're
trying to help curate their process and
experience and so we're trying to
accomplish a lot with that um so good
design is always intentional so
sometimes you see things like this this
picture of a bathroom I always loved
going into public places and finding
things
we're design wasn't intentional somebody
threw up some doors without even
thinking about it and it's just like
this poor person is you know using the
bathroom and just opened up to the world
and just in this miserable experience
and now that can happen all the time
when you just throw to throw stuff
together visually on the front end and
expect the user to to do what you want
without thinking about it and it's tough
I tell our designers and myself to think
about all the time so it's really
important to keep that in mind ah design
helps make decisions so this is another
picture keeping in the bathroom theme of
just an awkward experience so there's a
men's room and there's a woman's room
but the men's room is kind of pointing
to the women's room so you're kind of
like well am I going to expect urinals
in this room or am I going to a bunch of
stalls and you're just going to find
yourself in an awkward experience so we
want to make everything the user does we
want them to know exactly what they're
getting into before they get into it
design helps communicate so I don't know
this this sign isn't doing a great job
of communicating so please no smoking
alcohol on the beach I have not seen
anybody smoking alcohol at jas comp if
you are that's crazy but cool so let's
just think about what we're trying to
communicate when we're doing stuff um so
let's go over the basics I'm going to
give you a couple tips just to keep in
mind while you're designing stuff while
you're building web applications on the
front end side of the user facing side
these will be tips that you can write
down and just think about these are good
conversational elements to have with
your designers please push back on your
designers they'll probably hate me for
telling you about this but um they want
to be pushed just like you want to push
them up in your code reviews and all
that stuff so the basics number one
hierarchy this is a really important
thing when a user comes to your page and
they don't know what to click what are
you supposed to do so the thing I tell
people is you want to pick out out
number one on number two and a number
three so what's the most important thing
on the page it should be the most
obvious thing that's your number one
number two it should be obvious that
it's a number two so we'll go through an
example a good way to tell this is a
squint test I'm kind of doing it for you
blurring it so you can see the top
example it has just this basic block of
text when you squint your eyes and you
look over at the right it's kind of just
blurring together at the user doesn't
really know what's more important
information so they don't know how to
make a decision based on that if you go
to the bottom we've bolded the text for
the headline eat more vegetables and
we've put a button we've made the call
to action sign up button a bit more
important so that's the second most
important thing on the element and then
there's display text to help reinforce
that but that's a good thing to keep in
mind when you're doing things just make
things hierarchy make the most important
things obvious and then go from there um
balance is another thing sometimes you
go to a web page and it can be all
everything's on the left-hand side and
there's some input like important
information out hanging out but it looks
like it's going to fall over so this
example is we have a line straight down
the middle of this page this line is
dividing the white block in half but on
the the left-hand example the big blue
block is like taking up so much space
and it's dominating it so it's making
everything feel like it's going to shift
over to the left now to offset that on
the right hand example um a trick you
can do is kind of move the little guys
away so it's creating the illusion of
tier I that everything is more centered
contrasts now contrast is another
important thing this goes with hierarchy
and all I mean it's it's definitely a
friend of hierarchy it's going to help
you make things more hierarchical the
hierarchical and it's going to help
users to understand what you're trying
to get them to do a great example of
this is of the Spotify screenshot so the
most high contrast thing you see on the
page the first thing you see is that
green button gets Spotify in the top
right-hand corner that's an obvious
statement everything else on the page is
thing to it but really Spotify wants you
to get the app so just click that that's
pretty much what they're telling you to
do so the most obvious user action on
the page you want them to be high
contrast you don't want it to blend in
you don't want it to fade to the
background because that's the action you
want the user to take light space okay
you always everybody needs space
everybody needs room to breathe this is
an important thing in design you want to
make sure your your blocks and elements
are separated on the page and they're
not all mingling together so on the
first example here to the left we have a
block of text with a picture and it all
kind of runs together there's there's no
distinction between the elements it's a
muddy mess you don't really know what's
happening if you move over to the right
we've opened it up a bit too much so
everything is competing so the eat
vegetables the all those lines are
broken up in such a way that they're all
individual elements they're not a block
they're not whole so all the way to the
right it feels a little better we've
separated the headline we have the
blocks of text that feel like a whole
but they're not scrunched together and
there's room for the user to really
digest the information the important
thing here is just digestibility if you
go to a web page and a web app and you
have no clue how to read it and it's
just overbearing your users are just
going to click away as soon as possible
unless they're really really interested
alignment this is another thing that's
going to help users eyes so in this
example you've all seen like the columns
profile pictures on the left hand side
text you know like your basic twitter
app the reason designers are sometimes
super picky about I want this to be
moved over one pixel or they should be
um if they're picky just because if they
don't have a reason to sell you on this
then don't listen to them but the reason
you want to keep stuff really aligned is
because you want the users I to be to
scroll down to the page so this creates
a visual line for the user to scroll
there I down to the page if you break
that then the user is not going to
follow you down the page and you're not
going to be able to guide them as much
consistency this is a huge one um like
one of my points before design should be
intentional things should be consistent
in this presentation you've seen i'm
using and and there's a gray area for
that but it's like you should have a
basic idea of how you want things to
flow i have i've used a couple different
colors i have a couple different fonts
but everything I'm doing I'm trying to
keep consistent so if you add a new UI
element it should go along with the rest
of your brand so if you've if you have
added something to the front of your
site and you have say you're all your
buttons are styled and then you throw in
a new button and it's a default browser
button then the user is not going to
become it's they're going to be a little
confused they might not trust your app
quite as much so just being intentional
about the little things is going to
really set you apart and bring some
clarity and trust to everything you do
this is just an example you can go
online there's tons of UI libraries and
stuff that you can pull apart you know
you all know bootstrap and stuff
bootstraps great um but I want to help
you guys understand bootstrap a little
bit more so you can make bootstrap a
little boot less bootstrap II and more
custom to what you want so let's go
through some of these points and let's
go through and make a little widget okay
so we're going to go through everything
I've talked about so far and we're going
to talk about it so number one here's
our little silly little widget where are
you from help us customize your
experience and then a little drop-down
menu with a submit button so we're just
going to start off bit by bit point by
point and let's go through and tighten
this up a little bit more visually so
hierarchy we talked about hierarchy
first the first thing we're going to do
is okay let's increase the size of the
question the main question we're asking
the user that should be the first thing
like they need to know what they're
getting into that helper tests isn't the
help us customize your experience isn't
super important um it could be but we're
going to bring down the point size so
separating the
headline and the helper text is going to
help us create hierarchy number two is
balance okay so you can see and I'm
going left is the previous widget and
right is what we're updating so it's a
little unbalanced everything shifted
over to the right or to the left hand
side on the left hand widget and it's it
just seems a little sloppy unintentional
so this will bring in tension year
design so you want everything to feel
balanced let's Center everything put it
in the middle and make sense contrast
okay well let's make it a little bit
let's increase the hierarchy let's make
things a little bit more apparent what
we want the user to do so we we made the
submit button green added more contrast
to it obvious that we want them to click
and we took down the contrast of the
help us customize this experience
because it's still not that important so
we're we're going to tone it back even
more so contrast will help us build even
more hierarchy white space okay so this
text is feeling a little this widgets
feeling a little crammed and we have
plenty room of room on this page to add
some white space so we opened up the
padding on the sides we gave the submit
button a little bit more padding so it's
even more of a call to action and it
makes sense but when we did that we are
we did we forgot to align our the
drop-down menu with the submit button so
that's something that on the left hand
side it looks kind of like a mistake but
if you put it in a little bit more
effort you have those things align
that's the polish that it's going to
make your users just appreciate little
things and add a little bit of trust to
what you're doing um consistency now
this would be this one might be a little
bit hard for for some people to pick up
but it's just something to train your
eye to look for the inconsistent thing
here is the fonts and this is where I
might lose you a little bit but I hope I
keep you is it the fonts in the
drop-down menu and the fonts and the
submit button are different than the
other fonts on the left hand side so
it's it's a small nuance but if you can
start picking up on those things and
like I just have a
fault font on the left hand side but I
realized oh man i'm using Helvetica so I
let's just update everything to hell
vatika because it's more intentional
it's an intentional decision um so we
have a before and after shot now this is
like this is pretty big difference in my
eyes as a user or as a designer um these
are small updates that we made there
nothing huge there's nothing
groundbreaking about them all I'm doing
is I'm thinking about what I'm doing so
I just encourage you guys to keep these
points in mind while you're designing
apps while you're building your side
projects so you can make them more
successful and so you can push back on
your designers when they hand you stuff
and get involved even in the design
conversation as well so that's it um if
you want to learn more please go to hack
design dot org or good UI org those are
really awesome you um resources for
developers hack design is a curated
weekly email for developers who want to
level up on their design skills but it's
super helpful so I just want to thank
you guys I'd love to talk with you after
if you're interested in you know merging
your design and development teams and
how to bring communication between those
and if you just want to talk design or
talk development I'd love to talk with
you or talk with any of our lockers over
there we're looking for more awesome
people so if that kind of work interest
you the hybrid approach and you're a
developer and want to get more into the
design side we're definitely doing matta
olek so thank you guys have a great day
by travelpod member